on en parle avec entonné moussouris
verts qui restaurateur propriétaire du
mousseau à montréal au centre ville
bonsoir bonjour monsieur fillon votre
histoire est intéressant de vous vous
avez votre restaurant depuis sept ans
vous avez bien sûr comme tout le monde
notre vécu la pandémie vous venez de
rouvrir votre restaurant après tous ces
mois de pandémie et récemment dans
l'actualité vous avez publié un texte où
vous dites c'est la dernière chance que
j'accorde à ma passion pour la cuisine
dites nous pourquoi
même pas ce que c'est vraiment un milieu
donc moi ça fait 22 ans je suis dans ce
milieu là l'installation ça fait au
moins dix ans que je propriétaire
c'est un milieu qui est extrêmement
difficile extrêmement demandant et dans
lequel les marges sont très faibles donc
en bout de l'île l'essoufflement et en
plus on ajoute à cela la crise
avec l'aco vide tous ceux élus fragilisé
ce milieu puis c'est un milieu qui
vraiment qui a besoin de changement mais
qui ne peut pas changer parce que la
clientèle et ils mènent certains
entrepreneurs restent à la table on
parle de changement parce que ils vont
ils ont par le père peut-être perdre une
clientèle 6 augmentera au prix et en
même temps la clientèle elles
recherchent souvent le meilleur la
meilleure offre donc ça vient de
balancer ça vient des bases et plusieurs
secteurs dans notre industrie qui
moi me m'ont mis un peu à bout d'une
certaine façon qu'est ce qui est des
balances et pourquoi le modèle
d'affaires fonctionne plus ou moins bien
belle faut comprendre que le coût de la
vie a vraiment augmenté dans les
dernières années les salaires et les
prix des restaurants ont pas vraiment
suivi lors on sort d'une crise on le
voit je pense que les gens peuvent
vraiment le voir à l'épicerie les
produits ont vraiment monté mais c'est
la même chose pour nos produits à nous
en plus quand on est un restaurant comme
le mien et qu'on veut vraiment donner
une certaine qualité mais il y a
vraiment un prix qui avec les
ingrédients de bonne qualité et c'est
moi je me suis donné un peu la mission
de faire comprendre aux gens que
derrière là derrière une assiette n'y a
pas seulement le prix qu'on voit
énormément de travail il ya énormément
des gens qui sont touchés par ça et qui
est un con que peut-être que le client
québécois réalisent en fait qui devrait
peut-être sortir - mais sortir mieux est
vraiment encourager les particuliers qui
font un effort de mettre de l'avant les
produits et de mettre notre faire rouler
une économie locale et de mettre en
avant des produits locaux aussi parce
que les gens
sont habitués ne pas payer trop cher et
que c'est difficile pour vous d'arrivée
puis de dire ben voilà chez obligés
d'augmenter mépris parce que je vais
augmenter la qualité puis je vais
augmenter les salaires de mes employés
oui moi mais moi c'est ce que j'ai fait
moi je parle vraiment pour moi la lettre
c'est pas je prends pas pour tous les
restaurateurs c'est pour tous les
restaurateurs qui ont la même
possibilité mais en groupe jusqu'à ce
que je veux c'est vraiment expliquer aux
gens qui ont tout il faut en fait laissé
les installateurs montée des prix et se
remettre à niveau si on veut que la
gastronomie perdu parce que sinon on va
se retrouver avec la course aux beaux
prix est ce qu'ils vont faire que les
restaurants qui vont vouloir passer la
qualité vont devoir éventuellement
fermer et on va se retrouver avec des
produits génériques qui vont alimenter
d'autres économies que la nôtre
déballant serait un peu le tout ce qu'on
a construit depuis des années dans la
gastronomie ici est ce que le jeu
premier c'est d'augmenter salaires des
de tout le monde dans vos activités mais
moi c'est un enjeu parce que
la restauration ce milieu qui bouge
énormément c'est très long que les gens
restent plusieurs années dans un resto
verts surtout peut-être tous dans les
hôtels ou les institutions mais dans un
restaurant il n'y a pas de programme
d'assurance c'est pas des mêmes
conditions et c'est rare que les gens
restent plusieurs années moi j'ai voulu
créer un modèle un modèle dans lequel
les les employés auraient envie de
rester parce que c'est
bien beau de travailler dans cette
passion là mais il faut aussi pouvoir
avoir une fille sur le côté alors on
offre un des meilleurs salaires des
mêmes conditions en réduisant les heures
et les semaines de travail on en est
arrivé à construire un nouveau modèle
dont je sais pas encore à quel point ça
va être viable je fais ce fait un mois
qu'on est réouvert donc je vais voir ça
va prendre un an peut-être pour vraiment
mettre pour vraiment voir le situation
va perdurer mais ça nous permet vraiment
pour nous de changer des choses nous
donner un nouveau modèle d'affaires et
de données de mètres de là veulent le
bien être des cuisiniers et des employés
pour vraiment pouvoir les garder et
ensuite de sa qui se sentent reconnus
dans leur métier des gens qui ont étudié
deux ans induit en cuisine puis dont dix
ans l'expérience
menée ils ont le droit une qualité de
vie et ça on doit faire un effort je
pense tout les restaurateurs doivent
faire un effort maintenant je pense que
tous les sénateurs le font déjà aussi on
est vraiment vers une voie de changement
dans la restauration mais comme monsieur
picard expliqué les mêmes sont tellement
petit que ça devient dur pour des
restaurateurs de vraiment pouvoir
augmenter 2 - les salaires donc les
pourboires les partages de pouvoir c'est
vraiment une très bonne solution mais il
faut aller plus loin aussi et vous donc
vous jouer le tout pour le tout dans
dans cette nouvelle façon de faire les
choses dans votre ouverture ben écoutez
joie sont un peu comme ce jeu je sais
pas si en fait moi je prends vraiment
pour moi c'est la gastronomie en fait je
dois peut-être que bon si ça marche pas
je pourrais éventuellement m'ouvre et
une cantine depuis quelque chose de très
très très simple lorsqu'on le plaisir de
le pouvoir fera quelque chose de
compliqué mais
si je pense que oui c'est la dernière
chance quelques et je donne un ma
passion qui la gastronomie parce que ça
m'a pris trop ça m'a pris énormément
d'énergie dans les dernières années ça
me coûtait
yannick ou le sortait aussi qu'il vienne
avec ça et puis je voulais je veux faire
en sorte de ne pouvoir être bien
je donne ce dernier coup ça marche très
bien en ce moment la réaction des gens
est très positive on le voit ça nous a
donné une énergie au restaurant qu'ils
ont ils ont vraiment donné envie de
repartir et qu'ils ont redonné l'amour
du métier et ça ça vraiment changé donc
je suis très positif face à ce que nous
savons que la lettre a été écrit avant
l'ouverture du restaurant soyez donc
j'étais peut-être dans un mode un peu
plus un peu plus au fond c'était très
inquiétant un peu sombre mais lorsque ça
va très bien et puis j'espère que ça va
continuer comme ça donc j'y crois encore
un peu maintenant mais oui c'est la
dernière fois je pense que je le sais
mon chandail
d'accord gardez le pour l'instant bonne
chance à tous au liban merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup merci par nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit